jake tapper's show is absolutely
tanking and you know yesterday when i
was talking about stelter
i was making the point and i've made
this several times this idea of do we
have to talk about these people anymore
and i think it can be argued either way
whether we should talk about them or we
shouldn't right because it's like
on one hand we should just ignore them
and if we just ignored them maybe they
would just go away because very few
people are watching
and on the other hand they have this
very incestuous i would say insidious
relationship
with all the websites and big tech so it
always seems that their influence is a
lot bigger than it is
so we should call them out for the
nonsense so jake tapper who really was a
decent journalist
and i suspect is probably a decent guy
but you end up working at cnn
and you're it's like they give you a
lobotomy once you're there
uh well his show uh the lead with jake
tapper it is just tanking in the ratings
we've got some quotes here
from fox news cnn's the lead with jake
tapper
has shed a staggering 75
of its audience since the liberal
network experienced a january
spike in viewers tapper's program
averaged
2.8 million viewers in january but
settled for only 706 000 in the 4pm
eastern time slot from may 31st through
june 23rd
losing three quarters of its audience in
the process
tapper's second quarter viewership is
down 49
compared to the first quarter tapper has
also lost significant viewers among the
key news demographics of adults 25 to 54
dropping 79 of january's audience during
the first three weeks of june
in his time slot tapper's show is down
47
in the second quarter compared to q1
among the category most coveted by
advertisers
in april cnn awarded tapa with an extra
hour and expanded the show from 4 to 6
p.m eastern
but the move hasn't paid off in the
ratings department for the struggling
network
the lead average only 799 000 viewers
during the 5 to 6 pm eastern window
through june 23rd while fox news is the
5 average 2.6 million during that same
time slot
uh to beat tapper by a whopping 229
percent okay look i i don't want you to
get completely lost
in the numbers there and ratings this
and ratings that and the nielsen ratings
even make sense anymore who's got the
little
nielsen box in their television like
this is in 1954
but there's a wider issue here which is
what are people paying attention to and
why are they paying attention to it and
when are they paying attention to it
so why were jake tapper's ratings really
great in january
let me think for a second guys was there
something happening in early january
was there some sort of fraudulent second
impeachment
and a whole thing where there was a guy
wearing horns in the capitol
and something something it was like an
episode of the simpsons yeah these
people
need donald trump donald trump became
god to these people he became the center
of the universe to these people
and without donald trump nobody wants
to watch their drivel nobody wants to
watch
their democrat propaganda and tapper is
now suffering because of that
and the fact that they gave him an extra
hour and that didn't help
and the funny thing is well you know
when i in good times when when the
country is open and i go around and i
speak and i go to colleges
when i give talks and i obviously talk
about cable news a lot and
censorship and all of these things cnn
is the punch line
i don't even need a joke i just say cnn
the kids start laughing
because it's so ridiculous to them so
this is really interesting and if you
wonder
why suddenly people are starting to talk
about trump again we're going to get to
bronze al gore in just a second if you
wonder why they're still talking about
trump
and why they can't let the insurrection
that nobody brought a gun to
that was over in an hour why they can't
let it go
it's because of orange man they need him
if this was broke back mountain that
would be jake gyllenhaal
saying to uh what's his name who is the
joker and uh heath ledger
saying that he's ledger i can't quit you
i think he said it to him who said i
can't quit you to the other who said it
i think it was jake gyllen yeah jake
gyllenhaal
said to heath ledger i wish or i wish i
could quit you or something like that
he wanted to quit him you know what i
mean it wasn't easy to be gay back in
the mountains
that back then okay and that's what
that's the relationship that these
people have
with donald trump they wish they could
quit him but they can't quit him
because they love him and they need him
and they want to sleep with him